hi there I'm Samuel a multi-platform
cloud architect and I'm very excited and
honored to walk you through this
learning series about AWS let me start
the session with this scenario let's
imagine how life would have been without
Spotify for those who are hearing about
Spotify for the first time as bada phi
is an online music service offering and
it offers instant access to over 16
million licence to songs Spotify now
uses AWS cloud to store the data and
share it with their customers but prior
to AWS they had some issues imagine
using Spotify before AWS let's talk
about that back then users were often
getting errors because what if I could
not keep up with the increased demand
for storage every new day and that led
to users getting upset and users
canceling the subscription the problem
Spotify was facing at that time worse
their users were present globally and
were accessing it from everywhere and
they had different
latency in their applications and spot
if I had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalogue the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20,000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
AWS and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem AWS offered a
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed
AWS also offered tools and techniques
like storage lifecycle management and
trusted advisor to properly utilize the
resource so we always get the best out
of the resource used AWS address their
concerns about easily being able to
scale yes you can scale the AWS
environment very easily how easily one
might ask it's just a few button clicks
and AW solved Spotify is problem let's
talk about how it can help you with your
organization's problem let's talk about
what is AWS first and then let's bleed
into how a w's became so successful and
the different types of services that aw
spreads and what's the future of cloud
and areas and specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with AWS all right let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon Web
Services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay-as-you-go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or capital costs we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with AWS you can also
do Identity and Access Management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on-demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers hundred-plus services and this
list is growing every new week now that
would make you wonder how AWS became so
successful
of course it's their customers let's
talk about the list of well-known
companies that has their IT environment
in AWS Adobe Adobe uses AWS to provide
multi terabyte operating environments
for its customers by integrating its
system with AWS cloud a'dope can focus
on deploying and operating its own
software instead of trying to you know
deploy and manage the infrastructure
Airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the Airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iPhones and Android
applications Airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in AWS and they are
almost using all the services in AWS and
are getting benefited from it another
example would be Autodesk Autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like Amazon RDS or
rational database service and Amazon s3
or Amazon simple storage service
Autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure AOL or
American online uses AWS and using a
double layers they have been able to
close data centers and
decommission about 14,000 in house and
co-located servers and move
mission-critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
BitDefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
software's include antivirus and
anti-spyware products
BitDefender uses ec2 and they're
currently running few hundred instances
that handle about five terabytes of data
and they also use elastic load balancer
to load balance the connection coming in
to those instances across availability
zones and they provide seamless global
delivery of service because of that the
BMW Group it uses AWS for its new
connected car application that collects
sensor data from BMW 7-series cars to
give drivers dynamically updated map
information Canon's offers imaging
products division benefits from faster
deployment times lower cost and global
reach by using AWS to deliver
cloud-based services such as mobile
print the office imaging products
division uses AWS such as Amazon s3 and
Amazon route 53 Amazon CloudFront and
Amazon I am for their testing
development and production services
comcast is the world's largest cable
company and the leading provider of
internet service in the United States
comcast uses AWS in a hybrid environment
out of all the other cloud providers
comcast chose AWS for its flexibility
and scalable hybrid infrastructure
docker is a company that's helping
redefine the way developers build ship
and run applications this company
focuses on making use of containers for
this purpose and in AWS the service
called the Amazon ec2 container service
is helping them achieve it the ESA or
European Space Agency although much of
ASA's work is done by satellites some of
the program's data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on Amazon Web
Services years they chose AWS because of
its economical pay-as-you-go system as
well as its quick startup time The
Guardian newspaper uses AWS and it uses
a wide range of alw services including
Amazon Kenny
is Amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time Financial Times FD is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used Amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon richard
perform so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
Amazon redshift FD is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before General Electric GE is at the
moment as we speak
migrating more than nine thousand
workloads including 300 desparate ERP
systems to AWS while reducing its
datacenter footprint from thirty four to
four over the next three years
similarly Howard Medical School HTC I am
Debbie McDonald's NASA Kellogg's and lot
more are using the services Amazon
provides and are getting benefited from
it and this huge success and customer
portfolio is just the tip of the iceberg
and if we think why so many adapt aww us
and if we let AWS answer that question
this is what AWS would say people are
adapting AWS because of the security and
durability of the data and end-to-end
privacy and encryption after data and
storage experience we can also rely on
AWS way of doing things by using the AWS
tools and techniques and suggested best
practices built upon the years of
experience it has gained flexibility
there is a greater flexibility in AWS
that allows us to select the OS language
and database easy to use swiftness in
deploying we can host our applications
quickly in AWS beed a new application or
migrating an existing application into
AWS scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement car
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that AWS
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you
see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and swimming mission learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because AWS
is creating it as we speak
now let's look at some of them that are
very commonly used within computer
services we have Amazon ec2 Amazon
Elastic Beanstalk Amazon light sale and
Amazon lambda Amazon ec2 provides
compute capacity in the cloud now this
capacity is secure and it is resettable
based on the users requirement now look
at this the requirement for the web
traffic keeps changing and behind the
scenes in the cloud ec2 can expand its
environment to three instances and
during no load it can shrink its
environment to just one resource elastic
Beanstalk it helps us to scale and
deploy web applications and it's made
with a number of programming languages
elastic Beanstalk is also an easy-to-use
service for deploying and scaling web
applications and services deployed a
beat in java.net PHP node.js Python Ruby
docker and lot other familiar services
such as Apache passenger and IAS we can
simply upload our code and elastic
Beanstalk automatically handles the
deployment from capacity provisioning to
load balancing to auto scaling to
application health monitoring and Amazon
lightsail is a virtual private server
which is easy to launch and easy to
manage Amazon Lite cell is the easiest
way to get started with AWS for
developers who just need a word should
private server light cell includes
everything you need to launch your
project quickly on a virtual machine
like SSD based storage a virtual machine
tools for data transfer DNS management
and a static IP and that do for a very
low and predictable price AWS lambda has
taken cloud computing services to a
whole new level it allows us to pay only
for the compute time no need for
provisioning and managing servers and
Ariel Lewis lambda is a compute service
that lets us run chord without
provisioning or managing service lambda
execute your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands for second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when you call
is not running let's look at some
storage services that Amazon provides
like Amazon s3 Amazon glacier Amazon abs
and Amazon Elastic file system Amazon s3
is an object storage that can't store
and retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps IOT sensors and so on
can easily use Amazon s3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and to try any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility in managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides Amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
Amazon EBS Amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone EBS volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance and Amazon
Elastic file system or EFS provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with AWS cloud service and resources
that are on premises an Amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with Amazon Cloud Services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily Amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files to your application have the
storage they need and when they need it
now let's talk about databases
the two major a database flavors are
Amazon RDS and Amazon redshift Amazon
RDS it really eases the process involved
in setting up operating and scaling a
rational database in the cloud Amazon
RDS provides cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating
time-consuming administrative tasks such
as hardware
database setup patching and backups it
sort of frees us from managing the
hardware and sort of helps us to focus
on the application it's also
cost-effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services Amazon redshift
Amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using SQL and other business
intelligence tools Amazon redshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost-effective
and lays all your data using standard
SQL and your existing business
intelligence tools it also allows you to
run complex and allottee queries against
terabyte of structured data using
sophisticated query optimizations and
most of the results they generally come
back in seconds all right let's quickly
talk about some more services that AWS
offers there are a lot more services
that AWS provides but are we gonna look
at some more services that are widely
used aw application discovery services
help enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on premises data centers and a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependency mapping
or important early first step in
migration process and this alw SAP
Legation discovery service collects and
presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable cloud domain name
system or DNS service and Amazon route
53 is fully compliant with ipv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as Amazon
ec2 instance containers and IP addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zone and also across
availability zones a double is auto
scaling it monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performer
at a lowest possible cost using AWS
auto-scaling it's easy to setup
application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for DB services
AWS Identity and Access Management it
enables you to manage access to AWS
services and resources securely using I
am you can create and manage AWS
users and groups and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to AWS
resources and moreover it's a free
service now let's talk about the future
of AWS well let me tell you something
cloud is here to stay here's what in
store for AWS in the future as your
sparse by we're gonna have variety of
cloud applications born like IOT
artificial intelligence business
intelligence server less computing and
so on cloud will also expand into other
markets like healthcare banking space
automated cars and so on as I was
mentioning some time back Lord our
greater focus will be given to
artificial intelligence and eventually
because of the flexibility and advantage
that cloud provides we're gonna see a
lot of companies moving into the cloud
all right let's now talk about how easy
it is to deploy and web application in
the cloud so the scenario here is that
our users like a product and we need to
have a mechanism to receive input from
them about their likes and dislikes and
you know give them the appropriate
product as per their need all right
though the setup and the environment it
sort of looks complicated we don't have
to worry because AWS has tools and
technologies which can help us to
achieve it no we're gonna use services
like route 53 services like cloud watch
ec2 s3 and lot more and all these put
together are gonna give an application
that's fully functional and an
application that's gonna receive the
information like using the services like
route 53 cloud watch ec2 and s3 we're
gonna create an application and that's
gonna meet our need so back to our
original requirement all I want is to
deploy a web application for a product
that keeps our users updated about the
happenings and the new comings in the
market and to fulfill this requirement
here is all the services we would need
ec2 here is used for provisioning the
computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloud watch for
monitoring the environment and cloud
watch monitors the application and the
environment and it provides trigger for
scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use route 53 for DNS and route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
catters our need all right so I'm gonna
use elastic Beanstalk for this project
and the name of the application is gonna
be as you see GSG sign up and the
environment name is GSG sign up
environment one
let me also pick a name let me see if
this name is available yes that's
available that's the domain name so let
me pick that and the application that I
have is gonna run on node.js so let me
pick that platform and launch now as you
see elastic Beanstalk this is gonna
launch an instance it's going to launch
the monitoring setup or the monitoring
environment it's going to create a load
balancer as well and it's going to take
care of all the security features needed
for this application
all right look at that I was able to go
to that URL which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the cord or a
specific the page required so let's do
that let me upload the code I already
have the code saved here that's my code
and that's gonna take some time all
right
it has done its thing and now if I go to
the same URL look at that I'm being
thrown an advertisement page right so if
I sign up with my name email and stuff
like that you know it's gonna receive
the information and it's gonna send an
email to the owner saying that somebody
had subscribed to your service that's
the default feature of this app look at
that email to the owner saying that
somebody had subscribed to your app and
this is their email address stuff like
that not only that it's also going to
create an entry in the database and
DynamoDB is the service that this
application users to store data
there's my dynamo DB and if i go to
tables alright and go to items i'm gonna
see that a user with named Samuel and
Eva ladder so-and-so has said okay or
has shown interest in the preview of my
site or product so this is where this is
how I collect those information right
and some more things about the
infrastructure itself is it is running
behind an load balancer look at that it
had created a load balancer it had also
created an auto scaling group now that's
the feature of elastic load balancer
that we have chosen it has created an
auto scaling group and now let's put
this URL you see this it's it's not a
fancy URL alright it's an Amazon given
URL and dynamic URL so let's put this
URL behind our DNS let's do that so go
to services go to route 53 go to hosted
zone and there we can find the DNS name
right so that's a DNS name right
let's create an entry and map that URL
to our load balancer right and create
now technically if I go to this URL it
should take me to that application all
right look at that I went to my custom
URL and now that's pointed to my
application previously my application
was having a random URL and now it's
having a custom URL so what did we learn
we started the session with what is AWS
we looked at features and tools
technologies products that AWS provides
and we also looked at how AWS became
very successful again we looked into the
benefits and features of AWS in depth
and we also looked at some of the
services that Erebus provides in random
and then we picked particular services
and we talked about them like ec2
elastic beanstalk light sale glammed up
storage stuff like that then we also
looked at the future of AWS what AWS
holes in the store for us we looked at
that and then finally we looked at a lab
in which we created an application using
elastic Beanstalk and all that we had to
do was a couple of clicks and boom an
application was there available that was
connected to the database and that was
connected to the simple notification
system that was connected to cloud watch
that was connected to storage stuff like
that
I believe you really enjoyed this
session I'll meet you in another session
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here